that which does not kill us
makes us stronger
the true man wants two things
danger and play
for that reason he wants women
as the most dangerous plaything
sometimes people don't want to hear the
truth
because they don't want their illusions
destroyed
he who has a why to live for
can bear almost anyhow
i'm not upset that you lied to me
i'm upset that from now on
i can't believe you
you have your way
i have my way
as for the right way
the correct way
and the only way
it does not exist
[Music]
the surest way to corrupt a youth is to
instruct him to hold in higher esteem
those who think alike
than those who think differently
it is not a lack of love
but a lack of friendship
that makes unhappy marriages
the snake which cannot cast its skin has
to die
as well as the minds which are prevented
from changing their opinions
they cease to be mined
no one can construct for you the bridge
upon which precisely you must cross the
stream of life
no one but yourself alone
the advantage of a bad memory
is that one enjoys several times the
same good things for the first time
ultimately
it is the desire
not the desired that we love
perhaps i know best why it is man alone
who laughs
he alone suffers so deeply that he had
to invent laughter
[Music]
a thought
even a possibility
can shatter and transform us
to live is to suffer
to survive is to find some meaning in
the suffering
[Music]
it is nobler to declare oneself wrong
than to insist on being right
especially when one is right
open reality is the worst of all evils
because it prolongs the torments of man
you must be ready to burn yourself in
your own flame
how can you rise anew
if you have not first become ashes
[Music]
i know of no better life purpose than to
perish in attempting the great
and the impossible
[Music]
is life not a thousand times too short
for us to bore ourselves
[Music]
one must pay dearly for immortality
one has to die several times while still
alive
[Music]
i was in darkness
but i took three steps and found myself
in paradise
the first step was a good thought
the second
a good word
and the third
a good deed
[Music]
the higher man is distinguished from the
lower by his fearlessness
and his readiness to challenge
misfortune
the strength of a person's spirit would
then be measured by how much truth he
could tolerate
or more precisely
to what extent he needs to
have it deluded disguised
sweetened
muted
falsified
he who cannot put his thoughts on ice
should not enter into the heat of
dispute
[Music]
many are stubborn in pursuit of the path
they have chosen
view in pursuit of the goal
the lonely one offers his hand too
quickly
to whomever he encounters
he who obeys
does not listen to himself
[Music]
he who cannot obey himself will be
commanded
that is the nature of living creatures
man's maturity
to have regained the seriousness that he
had as a child at play
what was silent in the father speaks in
the sun
and often i found in the sun
the unveiled secret of the father
[Music]
so long as men praise you
you can only be sure that you are not on
your own true path
but
on someone else's
i notice that autumn is more the season
of the soul
than of nature
the secret of reaping the greatest
fruitfulness and the greatest enjoyment
from life
is to live dangerously
which quote did you like the most share
your opinion in the comments one day you
will regret that you did not hear these
quotes earlier do not lose the
opportunity watch our next video
[Music]